Okay.
One of the things that I struggle with while I'm solo parenting is,
like, getting out of the house,
getting dressed up, and going somewhere for fun.
Like, we go to the park and stuff,
but, like,
and run our errands, but other than that,
we don't go. I mean,
we don't have family or anything,
so it's not like we can, like,
go anywhere. Um,
we don't have family here,
so that's the hardest thing,
because then it, like,
you feel lonely. You're just, like,
every day feels the same. The days go by slower today.
Especially weekends. Weekends are like,
I need to get out of the house and, like,
do something. Um,
so today I'm like, you know what?
We're gonna get dressed, we're gonna, like,
do our makeup a little bit,
wear something cute, and we're gonna go to the mall.
You see that?
Tiene que salir normal.